die ereignisse überschlagen sich
inzwischen in deutschland sind
zahlreiche schutzmaßnahmen kraft
getreten 1000 menschen stehen im kreis
heinsberg unter quarantäne und etwa 60
sind in deutschland infiziert und
während die neuansteckungen in china
immer weiter nach unten gehen breitet
sich das virus weltweit aus im iran ist
laut fachleuten die epidemie massiv
ausgebrochen die zahl der 43 toten passt
überhaupt nicht zu den gemeldeten
fallzahlen von 388 fachleute schätzen
dass es im iran 18.300 infizierte gibt
in diesem video berichten wir über den
aktuellen stand erklären das virus und
seine herkunft genau und geben tipps wie
man das risiko sich anzustecken
dramatisch senken kann
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen heute mit dem
medizinstudenten und seinem neuen kanal
ein fach medizin
der link ist hier schon mal unterm
hammer kanal mit vielen vielen infos das
saas kopf 2 virus und die krankheit
cupid 19 die es auslöst ist eine der
größten globalen herausforderungen seit
jahrzehnten die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who schätzt
das risiko einer pandemie inzwischen als
sehr hoch ein
das epizentrum und der ursprungsort ist
die stadt wo hahn in der provinz hubei
in china dort wurden ende dezember
beziehungsweise anfang januar zuerst
mehrere fälle mit lungenentzündung
unbekannter herkunft gemeldet schnell
wurde das damals noch 2009/10 kopf
genannte virus also das neue corona
virus 2009 10 als verursacher entdeckt
und nach positiven proben der
fleischmarkt der stadt als quelle
identifiziert von dort breitete sich das
virus sowohl innerhalb chinas als auch
inzwischen international rasend schnell
aus inzwischen haben sich gut 80.000
personen damit infiziert und gut
zweieinhalb tausend sind daran gestorben
hey ich bin der medizin stellen vom
kanal ein fach medizin und ich schaue
mir heute genauer die medizinischen
aspekte
das ist der asko russ 2 an
wir fangen damit was ist dieser erreger
der krankheit 19 eigentlich genau woher
kommt ihr das saas corona virus 2 ist
wie der name schon sagt mitglied der
korona wir die ziemlich viele hamburger
vertreter haben also einige
schnupfenviren aber auch 1 2 wirklich
gefährliche wird das virus des mehr als
virus die in der vergangenheit auch
schon alleine ausbrüche und tote
verursacht haben zwischenzeitlich kamen
vermutungen hoch dass das saas corona
virus zwei eine im labor erstellte
biowaffe sein könnte die aus versehen
freigesetzt wurde
denn ein entsprechendes labor das risiko
für virologie ist eben nur einige
hundert meter von diesem ominösen
fleischmarkt entfernt der als
ursprungsort des neuen virus gilt den
widersprechen aber australische
britische und amerikanische forscher die
das virus genauer genetisch untersucht
haben laut ihnen ist es aufgrund der
genetischen struktur und auch der
struktur des rezeptors mit dem des
corona virus an den menschen bindet
extrem unwahrscheinlich dass dieses neue
virus eben im labor synthetisch
hergestellt wurde das saas krone die
russ 2 kommt höchstwahrscheinlich wie
das saas und das meer als auch von
corona die in die ursprünglich auf tiere
beschränkt waren dann mutiert sind so
dass sie den menschen infizieren konnten
und sich eben seitdem bei uns ausbreiten
ganz ursprünglich kommt es neue corona
wir es höchstwahrscheinlich von
fledermäusen die einfach sehr viele
coronaviren haben man ist sich aber
nicht ganz sicher ob dann die
übertragung wirklich direkt fledermaus
auf menge stattgefunden hat oder ob man
noch einen überträger tier in der mitte
hatte als überträger tier hat man
möglicherweise jetzt das schuppentier
identifiziert das ist dieses tier das in
china aufgrund seiner schoben und seines
fleisches illegal für die traditionelle
chinesische medizin missbraucht wird bei
dem haben forscher viren nachweisen
können die zum 99
mit dem saas corona virus zwei gleich
sind die große frage wie bekommt man das
virus das saas kopf zwei kann über
verschiedene wege übertragen werden der
haupt übertragungsweg des virus ist die
tröpfcheninfektion dadurch
qualifizierten hohe konzentrationen des
virus im nasen- und rachenraum
befinden die mit jedem sprechen husten
und niesen in die umgebung geschleudert
werden dass gefährliche beim saas kopf 2
ist das infizierte weitere personen
anstecken können selbst wenn sie nur
milde oder auch gar keine symptome haben
also auch bereits in der inkubationszeit
eine studie berichtet beispielsweise von
einem infizierten ohne symptome der
ähnliche virus konzentration in seinem
nasen-rachen-raum hatte wie klinisch
kranke und auch schwerkranke patienten
ein fall bericht ergab dass eine person
die niemals symptome entwickelt positiv
auf das virus getestet wurde und fünf
andere personen an steckte die ansonsten
keinen kontakt mit johann oder anderen
personen von dort hatten das ist deshalb
ein so riesiges problem da sich so
personen anstecken und dann wiederum
andere leute infizieren können ohne es
zu merken und das virus somit besonders
schwer einzudämmen ist darauf kann sich
kein gesundheitssystem vorbereitet
neben der klassischen tröpfchen
infektion kann das saas kopf zwei
wahrscheinlich auch über kontaminierte
oberflächen übertragen werden also ein
erkrankter ein erkrankter huste zuerst
in seiner hand fasst dann eine türklinke
hand danach kommt man selbst vorbei
fasst dort rein und man hat das virus
außerdem mit man inzwischen an dass auch
der fäkal orale übertragungsweg möglich
ist da man das virus ebenfalls im stuhl
mehrerer infizierter personen gefunden
hat da stellt sich natürlich die frage
ob man sich über pakete oder briefe aus
china infizieren kann
das ist laut wären nicht möglich da die
viren nicht lange genug außerhalb des
körpers überleben um hier über jemanden
anzustecken trotzdem wird zur sicherheit
empfohlen solche sendungen zu
desinfizieren
da sind die informationen
widersprüchlich fast aber in diesen
tagen immer häufiger passiert darauf
kommen wir noch aber was passiert wenn
man sich dann mal mit diesem virus
infiziert hat das saas corona virus zwei
bühnen an den sogenannten ac 2 rezeptor
auf der oberfläche von menschen zählt
freut sich damit in diese zellen ein und
fängt von dort an sich immer weiter im
körper zu verbreiten nach einer
inkubationszeit von ca 2 bis 14 tagen
die aber wahrscheinlich in einzelfällen
auch deutlich länger sein kann macht
dieses virus vor allem fieber und
atemwegs symptomatik und diese art dem
weg symptomatik die weist eine große
bandbreite auf das geht von so ein
bisschen kurzatmigkeit und husten die
nach ein paar tagen weg gehen über eine
lungenentzündung bis hin zum lungen
versagen dem sogenannten ard es den
exportorientierten rum und tod laut
einer studie mit über 70.000 infiziert
in china verlaufen ca 80 prozent der
kogit fälle mild circa 14 prozent der
fälle schwer und circa fünf prozent
kritisch und von diesen fünf prozent
kritischen fällen stürzinger die hälfte
der patienten also in diesem paper lag
die letalität bei circa 2,3 prozent
jedoch wurde je nach region - und auch
je nach zeitraum der infektion die
letalität durchaus relativ
unterschiedlich hoch aufgezeichnet
werden zb in hubei also der provinz wo
wirklich die stadt wuchern liegt wo das
ganze herkommt chinesen eine vitalität
von circa drei prozent hatten wiesen
alle restlichen regionen es nur eine
letalität um 0,4 prozent auf das liegt
zum beispiel daran dass einfach in hubei
so viele leute erkrankt sind und auch
entsprechend so viele leute kritisch
oder schwer erkrankt sind das einfach
die ressourcen mit das gesundheitssystem
überstrapaziert sind man die patienten
nicht mehr adäquat versorgen kann
und die dadurch eben schlechtere
überlebenschancen haben werden in den
anderen gebieten chinas wie zum beispiel
auch im rest der welt die fälle relativ
breit verteilt sind man gibt leute
dadurch eben besser versorgen kann
besser behandeln kann und die dadurch
eben öffne überleben man sieht an diesem
paper auch das je nach untergruppen also
zb altersgruppen geschlecht vor
erkannten usw
mit 19 sehr unterschiedlich gefährlich
sein kann zum beispiel bei den unter 40
jährigen lag die letalität wir bei ca
0,2 prozent dahingegen starben bei den
über 80-jährigen fast 15 prozent der
infizierten es gilt wird endlich je
älter desto gefährlicher ist das virus
auch bei den geschlechtern zeigen sich
unterschiede wenn man sich eben die
verstorbenen patienten die versprochenen
erkranken anschaut waren die zu zwei
dritteln männer nur ein drittel frauen
wären die erkrankungen ein
fifty-fifty in dieser studie waren nach
vorerkrankungen sind ein großes risiko
insbesondere bei bluthochdruck diabetes
uns vor bestehenden herz kreislauf von
lungenkrankheiten starten die leute
deutlich häufiger also dass er nicht
sogar space ist alt männlich und
vorerkrankungen sehr interessant ist
aber dass bei schwangeren infizierten
des virus anscheinend nicht auf das kind
also den petrus im bauch übertragen wird
denn mehrere kinder sind nach der geburt
negativ getestet wurden nach vorläufigen
berichten wie gesagt auch in der
altersgruppe unter einem jahr scheinen
co wird 19 vergleichsweise mild zu
verlaufen in einer fall wäre mit neun
babys musste keines intensivmedizinisch
behandelt werden brauchte eine beatmung
oder hatte sonst die schwere
komplikation das gibt natürlich hoffnung
man muss aber sagen dass man für
definitiven aussagen zu solchen kleinen
gruppen größere studien und größere
serien abwarten muss aber wie kann man
den patienten jetzt behandeln die disco
wird 19h leider muss man sagen gibt es
gegen das koma die russ 2 weder eine
impfung noch direkte medikamente und
antibiotika bringen ja nichts weil das
ganze ist eine virus- und kein bakterium
was man macht ist dass man diese sollte
symptomatisch behandelt das bedeutet
dass man den körper so lange unterstützt
bis er den kampf gegen das virus von
selbst gewinnen weil wir haben ja einen
moon systemen und das ist für so was da
letztendlich und diese symptomatische
behandlung das reicht von so basic
sachen wie fieber senken zum beispiel
oder flüssigkeit medikamente geben bei
entsprechenden bedürfnissen bis hin zur
intensivmedizinischen behandlung zb das
ads ist ja dieses jungen versagen ist er
wie schon erwähnt hat indem großes
problem kann zum tod führen hier muss
man die patienten zum beispiel an die
beatmung nehmen die maschinelle beatmung
so dass sich die lunge dann bitter zeit
erholen kann was auch passieren kann ist
dass bei diesem schweren und kritischen
fällen zum beispiel auf diese virale
infektion diese virale pneumonie eine
bakterielle superinfektion nochmal und
top drauf kommt dann muss man die leute
zum beispiel natürlich antibiotisch
behandeln und intensivmedizinisch kann
man noch alles mögliche anderen machen
bei kann den säure basen haushalt
ausgleichen
man kann die niere unterstützen bzw
nierenfunktion zwischenzeitlich
übernehmen
wenn ich alle möglichen organe
unterstützen weil kann eine sepsis
behandelt und so weiter
währenddessen wird fieberhaft versucht
eine impfung oder ein antivirale mittel
gegen das saas corona virus 2 zu finden
allein china hat über 80 klinische
studien initiiert die von
experimentellen medikamenten über
bekannte antivirale mittel
stammzelltransplantation serum infusion
bis hin zu traditioneller kräutermedizin
reichen die bisher erfolgsversprechend
sind kandidaten sind das experimentelle
antivirale medikamente mdb wir das
malariamittel chloroquin und die serum
transfusion das rennende serviert das
ist ein medikament das ursprünglich zur
behandlung von ebola entwickelt wurde
aber im vorigen experimenten eben auch
eine gute wirksamkeit gegen saßen
zellkulturen und den tieren gezeigt hat
saß ist ja sehr eng mit dem saß co oder
virus zwei verband deshalb hat man eben
hier der versuch gestartet und konnte
eben auch dann relativ schnell eine gute
wirksamkeit von rem diese wir gegen des
saas corona virus 2 in zellkultur
nachweisen anfang januar gab es dann ein
bericht von einem fall in den usa wo ein
patient mit rennen die wir behandelt
wurde sich darunter auch gebessert hat
und letztendlich genesen ist auch dass
malariamittel chloroquin zeigte sich in
zellkulturen effektiv gegen das saas
corona virus zwei weshalb man neben das
auch in einer studie ausprobieren wollte
die vorläufigen ergebnisse einer studie
lassen eben hoffen dass dieses mittel
möglicherweise gegen kuwait 19 helfen
kann man muss aber ehrlicherweise
wirklich die finalen ergebnisse dieser
klinische studien abwarten die für so
zirka ende april anfang mai zu erwarten
sind in einer weiteren studie wird das
serum von patienten die sich von kurve
19 schon erholt haben auf die leute die
noch eben damit erkrankt sind
transportiert idee dahinter ist dass
wenn man bloß infektion durchgemacht hat
die leute ganz spezifische antikörper
gegen das jeweilige virus im blut haben
in dem fall gegen das saas corona virus
2 im blut bedeutet in dem fall in serum
teil des blutes und die grundidee ist
letztendlich dann diese antikörper
zusammen mit dem serum in noch erkrankte
patienten zu transportieren um mit
diesem antikörper gegen
noch erkrankten patienten im kampf gegen
das virus zu helfen wie schwieriges aber
ist an medikamente zu kommen zeit
übrigens deutschland für den patienten
der in düsseldorf in lebensgefahr
schwebt hat der hersteller rim diese wir
nicht zur verfügung gestellt aber zurück
zu der ausbreitung des virus
zwischenzeitlich sah es so aus als hätte
man die verbreitung des saas kopf 2 in
den griff bekommen zwar gab es mitte
februar einen sprung in der
infektionsrate die ist jedoch auf eine
änderung der definition von infiziert
zurückzuführen vor der änderung wurden
nur definitiv test positiv getestete
patienten und patientinnen als
infizierte gezählt aufgrund des aufwands
dieses tests und der unglaublich großen
anzahl an lokale infizierten in china
und noch einmal vielen tausenden mehr an
verdachtsfällen wurde die zahl der
infizierten deutlich unterschätzt seit
der änderung der definition reicht eine
klinische diagnose man braucht in china
nicht mehr den genetischen nachweis
sondern wer kontakt mit dem virus hatte
entsprechend symptome und typische
veränderungen auf einem röntgenbild bzw
in der computertomografie zeigt wird als
infiziert gezählt das entspricht den
anforderungen der
weltgesundheitsorganisation who die
vorher nicht eingehalten worden waren
nach dieser neudefinition kam es nach
diesem kurzen sprung zu einem stagnieren
der infektionsrate in china doch die
gefahr ist noch nicht überstanden
das kreuzfahrtschiff diamond princess
und die aktuelle situation in südkorea
und italien und vor allem im iran zeigt
wie schnell die lage außer kontrolle
geraten kann
im iran sind offiziell 388 infizierte
gemeldet 43 erkrankten sind gestorben
sprich die sterblichkeit die letalität
würde ich hier bei mehr als zehn prozent
liegen das halt einfach leute für
absolut undenkbar und der kanadische
biologe eis sagt boch hat mit mehreren
co-autoren die zahl der infizierten dort
auf 18.300 hochgerechnet dafür haben die
forschenden daten anderer epidemie
verläuft und das aktuelle
passagieraufkommen zwischen iran und den
arabischen emiraten libanon und kanada
ausgewertet denn dort in diesen ländern
also irak libanon in kanada bahrain
kuwait und oman kamen die ersten
infizierten überhaupt auf dem iran
und bei eigenen recherchen ist die bbc
auf viel mehr opfer von saas kopf zwei
gestoßen demnach sind es sogar 210 tote
statt der gemeldeten 43 der iran ist
also im moment das weltweite epizentrum
das dortige gesundheitssystem scheint
heillos überfordert zu sein und die
führung scheint die katastrophe zu
verschweigen was aber einen noch
größeren katastrophe auslösen könnte
die whu warnt dementsprechend vor der
möglichen ausbreitung in ländern mit
schwachen gesundheitssystem wie eben im
mittleren osten oder in afrika
der afrikanische kontinent bereitet der
whu große sorgen bis jetzt sind
offiziell nur drei fälle in ägypten
nigeria und algerien bestätigt die engen
handelsbeziehungen chinas zu afrika auch
der provinz hubei im speziellen lassen
jedoch fürchten dass sich das virus dort
bereits unerkannt vermehrt und das
könnte bei einem schwachen
gesundheitssystem wie wir es dort finden
eine katastrophe sein und zu deutschland
das ansteckungsrisiko hier ist absolut
niedrig natürlich kann es einzelne
treffen die hier immer wieder zu sehen
ist aber im lotto gewinnt man zurzeit
viel leichter als ich mit dem corona
virus anzustecken trotzdem sagt das
nichts über die zukunft aus und da
könnte es sich schon bald anders
verhalten deswegen wird die
bundesregierung jetzt aktiv nachdem sie
vorher wochenlang lediglich beruhigt hat
erst jetzt hat bundesgesundheitsminister
jens spahn die länder aufgefordert ihre
pandemiepläne zu aktualisieren also ich
würde mal sagen lieber jetzt als
überhaupt nicht und dass unser
gesundheitssystem so gut aber eine
infektionswelle vorbereitet sei scheint
auch eher wunsch als wirklichkeit zu
sein laut spiegel recherche mussten 37
prozent aller krankenhäuser in
deutschland aus personalmangel im ersten
halbjahr 2009/10 intensivbetten sperren
das hört sich dann doch etwas anders an
als gut vorbereitet zudem gelten jetzt
neue regeln für den bahn- und
flugverkehr an flughäfen müssen reisende
aus risikoländern aussteiger karten
ausfüllen und ihren aufenthaltsort in
deutschland angeben in fügen müssen dass
menschen mit symptomen machen
großveranstaltungen werden jetzt
kritisch geprüft die internationale
tourismusbörse in berlin wurde schon
abgesagt in nordrhein westfalen stehen
jetzt im kreis heinsberg 1000 menschen
unterkamen
antenne bis die inkubationszeit
abgelaufen ist
diese ganzen informationen die wir hier
im video gesammelt haben sind natürlich
nur eine momentaufnahme jeden tag kommen
neue puzzleteile hinzu und jeden tag
kann sich die lage ändern und jetzt
haben wir noch eine reihe von tipps um
sich gegen das corona virus zu schützen
optimiert eure gesundheit und
immunsystem bedeutet vor allem mut und
viel schlafen eine ausgewogene ernährung
und regelmäßigen sport was häufig eure
hände um benutzt oft und idealerweise
nach dem händewaschen
ein desinfektionsmittel haltet
mindestens einen meter abstand von allen
personen die husten oder niesen beziehen
wir von allen die krank sind
achtet darauf euch so wenig wie möglich
im gesicht vor allem am und an der nase
oder an den augen zu berühren denn das
sind die klassischen eintrittspforten
für erreger wenn ihr selbst husten oder
niesen müssen entweder in ein
taschentuch was sie direkt danach
wegwerfen oder in die ellenbeuge wenn es
euch schlecht geht ihr fieber husten und
kurzatmigkeit habt geht wenn nötig erst
vom arzt nachdem ihr angerufen habe wenn
ihr diese symptome hat also auch schon
leichte wie nagel auf dem kopf schmerzen
kurzatmigkeit bis hin zu fieber husten
und wichtig ist es und ihr kontakt zu
einer person aus einem risikogebiet
hattet oder einem aktiven
infektionsgebiet oder ihr selbst aus
einem aktiven infektionsgebiet kommt
dann bevor ihr zum arzt geht ruft bitte
diesen an und sagt den bescheid oder
ruft das gesundheitsamt an und sagt den
bescheid wir haben einige notfall
rufnummern unten in die video
beschreibung gepackt damit ihr nicht
irgendwie ne seite zimmer mit 20 anderen
personen platz und diese ansteckt und
noch eine anmerkung das robert koch
institut rät von solchen atemmasken das
sind die dichterin da sind die einfachen
op masken ab da es keinen
wissenschaftlichen beweis gebe dass sie
wirkungsvoll sein
also ich habe zwei studien gefunden
zumindest nahe legen dass sogar op
masken ganz gut wirken aber vor allem
und das ist ein punkt schützen sie davor
sich selbst ins gesicht zu fassen was
man etwa 200 mal am tag intuitiv macht
und im gegensatz zur meinung des
robert-koch-instituts ist solches
verhalten nur schwer zu ändern zudem
schützen die masken andere wenn man
selbst infiziert ist sie machen also
geologisch sinn vielleicht im moment
weil kaum einer angesteckt ist das heißt
nicht dass sie absoluten schutz bieten
aber sie sind erst mal eine einfache
barriere von montana sind die beide
unbedingt vor den viren geschützt werden
müssen
was hilft also ein mundschutz einfach
mehr in zehn hat hier noch mehr infos
klicken anschauen und natürlich ein fach
medizin abonnieren da gibt es immer
wieder videos und
hintergrundinformationen über das saas
corona virus zwei bis dann bleibt dran